Have you ever wondered why, even
after these huge wins for
justice, you know, or, like,
massive public solidarity, all
that amazing momentum seems to
just, well, fizzle out?
Yeah.
It happens all the time.
Why does real progress often
feel like OK, 2 steps forward,
but then almost without you
noticing one step back?
It's easy to think, oh it must
be overt opposition, right?
Active malice, some group
pushing back hard.
That's the usual assumption,
yeah.
You see the push back, the loud
voices and you think, OK, that's
the problem.
But what if the real adversary
is something, I don't know,
quieter, Something working away
under the surface of our
collective good intentions?
It's a question that honestly,
anyone involved in trying to
make blasting change bumps up
against.
You see these incredible surges,
these moments where it feels
like, yes, society is really
going to shift.
Right, a real turning point.
Exactly.
And then without any clear
defeat, no obvious enemy
winning, that energy just
evaporates.
It leaves you thinking what is
going on here?
What unseen force is pulling
things back?
It's not just a set back.
It feels like a real Gen., you
know?
Totally.
And that's exactly what we're
diving into today.
It's this fascinating concept,
borrowed, believe it or not,
straight from physics Entropy.
We're going to explore how this
basic law applies to culture, to
society, leading to what our
main source calls cultural
entropy.
And the source we're digging
into?
fightingamericanculturalentropy.pdf.
It really does challenge the way
we usually think about what's
holding back progress, why it's
so hard to keep things moving
forward.
It really does.
It shifts the focus away from,
let's say, the usual suspects in
these social conflicts.
It points towards something much
more subtle, maybe even more
powerful in the long run.
It kind of reframes the whole
struggle, suggesting the real
opponent might not be who or
even what we assume it is.
So our mission for this deep
dive is really to unpack this
idea, cultural entropy.
We want to look at what the
source argues is the real
barrier, the often missed
obstacle for movements like,
say, anti racism, to achieve
lasting success.
Why fighting?
Just the obvious hate might be
missing the bigger picture.
Exactly, missing the quieter
adversary that just slowly
drains the energy out of
everything.
We hope to give you, our
listeners, a kind of fresh lens
to look at social change, its
challenges, and why sustaining
ideals is just so darn
difficult.
It's about getting underneath
the surface, isn't it?
Understanding the hidden
dynamics that shape progress,
or, you know, the lack of it,
rather than just reacting to the
headlines or the loudest voices.
This framework, honestly it
could change how we approach
trying to make a real lasting
difference all.
Right, let's get into it.
Let's cultural entropy starting
like the source does with the
physics.
For anyone needing a quick
science recap, what is entropy
in physics?
What does it measure?
What does it do?
OK, so in physics, entropy is
well, it's fundamental, you
can't escape it.
It's often described as
measuring disorder or
randomness, or even how much
energy in a system isn't
available to do useful work.
Disorder.
But maybe think of it like this.
It's the universe's built in
tendency for things to move from
order, structure and
concentrated energy towards
disorder, randomness and energy
spreading out evenly.
Everything wants to settle into
a kind of bland uniform state.
So things don't naturally tidy
themselves up.
Absolutely not.
Without a constant input of
energy from outside to maintain
structure, systems just
naturally decay.
They breakdown.
It's a basic law.
Things tend towards
disorganization, not
organization on their own.
So it's not just things when
falling apart, it's the energy
kind of spreading out, becoming
less focused, less useful, like
the universe is always trying to
smooth itself out, become less
interesting.
That's a great way to put it.
It's this natural tendency to
fall apart or drift towards a
state with less organized energy
and more disorder.
Think about everyday stuff.
Like what?
Give us some examples.
OK, picture a perfectly tidy
room, everything in its place.
Leave it alone for a week.
What happens?
Dust settles, maybe things get
slightly shifted, stuff gets
left out, it naturally, it's
messier, right?
That's entropy.
OK, yeah, my living room
confirms that daily.
Or a hot cup of coffee.
You pour it, it's piping hot.
Leave it on the table.
Does it get hotter?
No.
Does it stay hot forever?
It cools down to room
temperature.
It's heat energy spreads out
into the air until everything's
the same temperature.
Classic entropy increase.
Right, the energy dissipates.
Exactly.
Or think bigger.
A big strong building.
If you stop maintaining it, no
repairs, no painting, no one
fixing the roof, what happens
overtime?
It crumbles.
Materials weather.
The structure weakens, it falls
apart, becoming a less organized
pile of stuff.
It returns to the earth
basically.
Pretty much.
Or maybe the best one, a garden.
You cultivate it, you weed, you
prune, you water, you put in
constant energy.
Stop doing that.
Does it stay a perfect garden?
Definitely not.
Weeds take over.
Things get overgrown.
Right.
It goes back to wilderness.
Yeah, a more disordered, less
intentionally structured state.
All these examples show systems
breaking down without that
constant energy input needed to
maintain their complex ordered
state.
OK, that makes total sense.
It's almost disturbingly
intuitive how things degrade
without effort.
Yeah, but how do we take that,
you know, that physics concept
and apply it to something as
messy and human as culture and
society?
How does decay disorganization
applied to social systems?
Well, the source argues, that
applies very directly, often in
ways we don't recognize.
Just like a physical system, a
society, it's shared values, its
ideals like justice or equality,
it's collective memory, it's
institutions.
These things aren't static
achievements.
They're not just done.
Exactly.
They're dynamic.
They need constant, sustained
energy and deliberate effort to
keep them alive, vibrant,
working as intended.
Think about democracy, right?
Or enforcing equitable laws, Or
just keeping a focus on social
justice.
These aren't things you achieve
once and then forget about.
They're ongoing projects.
They need fuel.
So if that energy and constantly
put in that collective focus,
that sustained effort, we just
sort of drift, drift back to
what?
Some kind of default setting?
That's the core argument.
Without that constant energy
input, society inevitably drifts
back towards what's easy, what's
familiar, maybe just the path of
least resistance.
That drift is cultural entropy.
Like the coffee cooling down,
but on a societal scale.
Precisely.
Or the garden going wild.
But it's crucial to get this.
The source isn't saying it's
some active evil force pushing
us backward deliberately.
It's more passive, A pervasive
tendency for things to lose
their organized, intentional,
often hard one state.
Which implies something pretty
profound about progress, doesn't
it?
Really does it means progress
isn't some permanent state.
You reach lock in and then it
just days there by itself.
No, it's an ongoing energetic
effort against this natural
societal decay.
It's a constant uphill push
against the tendency towards
disorder, indifference and
slipping back to comfortable,
maybe unjust old ways.
It's like trying to stick to a
diet or exercise plan, right?
The initial motivation is
strong, but without that
consistent effort, the old
habits, the easy way, just
creeps back in.
That's a perfect analogy.
It requires continuous
willpower, continuous energy.
OK, so it's not active malice
pushing back, it's this quiet
passive drift.
And this idea of cultural
entropy leads us to what the
source calls the entropic
middle, which apparently really
challenges how we usually think
about what social movements are
up against.
Yeah, it completely shifts the
perspective.
We usually think that modern
movements say anti racism are
primarily fighting active
hatred, right?
Overt racist, white supremacist.
Those visible loud forces
opposing change.
We frame it as a battle of
ideas, US versus a clear them
who are actively hostile.
We focus on countering their
arguments, exposing them,
fighting their obstruction.
That's where the energy often
goes.
And the source basically says,
hold on, maybe you're aiming at
the wrong target, or at least
not the biggest target.
That the real larger challenge
isn't this loud minority
shouting back.
Exactly.
It argues that focus is a
misdirection, or at least
incomplete.
So if it's not the loud
minority, who is the true
adversary, according to this
source?
Who makes up this entropic
middle?
The true adversary, the source
argues, is the quiet majority.
It's the huge number of people
who simply do not move at all.
They're not actively resisting
necessarily, but they're not
actively participating either.
Just inert.
Largely, yes.
And we're not talking a small
group here.
The source actually puts a
number on it, suggesting that 70
to 90% of people live in this
entropic middle.
Wow, 70 to 90%, that is huge.
It's almost everyone.
It's a massive majority.
Imagine trying to push a
gigantic heavy object that has
absolutely no desire to move.
That's the scale of the
challenge.
The inertia of this group dwarfs
the active noisy opposition.
OK, So what defines this
entropic middle?
What are they like?
What are they doing, or maybe
more accurately, not doing?
What's their motivation, or lack
thereof?
Well, their typical state is one
of being busy, maybe distracted,
definitely disengaged from the
big societal struggles the
source describes them as.
Tired, yeah.
Focused on their day-to-day
lives, their jobs, their
families, paying the bills,
finding some comfort.
They work, they watch, they
retreat.
Retreat into their own bubbles.
Pretty much their main driver
isn't ideology, it's not active
opposition to progress.
It's more fundamental, more
human self preservation,
conserving energy, avoiding
discomfort.
They drift toward whatever feels
safe, and they instinctively
avoid conflict.
Sounds like basic human nature,
wanting comfort and quiet.
And the source stresses this.
It's not malice, it's not active
racism or active anti racism.
It's just human nature.
A deep preference for comfort
over engagement.
A reluctance to get involved in
anything that feels like
friction or trouble unless
they're absolutely forced.
To you just want to get through
the day, avoid drama, keep
things stable.
Exactly.
They might even agree with
Progressive goals and theory,
not along, but the actual energy
required to actively
participate, to consistently
challenge things.
That feels like too much.
Too draining, too risky maybe.
That makes a lot of sense
actually, the desire to avoid
conflicts.
Stick with comfort.
But OK, if the challenge is
moving this huge, inert,
comfortable mass that doesn't
want to move, why doesn't direct
pressure work?
Yeah, you know, moral arguments,
shaming tactics.
We see movements try that all
the time.
Right.
And it often seems to backfire,
doesn't it?
Yeah, it can feel like it makes
things worse sometimes.
Well, if the goal is to shift
this mass that wants to conserve
energy, direct pressure or
shaming is often, according to
the source, deeply
counterproductive.
Think about it, when people feel
pushed too hard, judged,
cornered, what's the natural
reaction?
To push back, you get defensive.
Exactly.
They push back, but it's not
necessarily an ideological push
back.
Like I disagree with your goal.
It's more visceral, defensive.
Stop attacking me, stop making
me feel bad.
And shaming.
Shaming is even trickier.
Does it make people change their
minds or behavior?
The source argues.
Often not.
Instead, they turn away.
They disengage even more.
They shut down, close off from
the message, become more
resistant to hearing it.
They dig in their heels.
Right.
Their reaction is basically to
hunker down, wait for the storm
to pass, and then quietly return
to what feels normal.
Which just reinforces that
entropic drift back to
indifference.
So pressure just activates their
defense mechanisms and makes
them retreat further into that
low energy state.
That's the argument which raises
a really tough question for
anyone trying to create change.
If moral pressure, shaming,
direct confrontation, if these
tools are ineffective or even
counterproductive with this huge
middle group, what strategies
are left?
How do you actually motivate
movement without triggering that
resistance?
That's a huge challenge, and it
really makes you rethink
strategy, doesn't it?
And this quiet, steady force
cultural entropy.
It also helps explain why
movements, even ones with
massive initial energy, seem to
lose seam fade away.
Yeah, it's like watching a
bright fire slowly die down to
embers.
Why does that happen?
What's the connection to
entropy?
Well, the core idea is that real
societal change, pursuing
justice, keeping movements
alive, it all requires immense
continuous energy.
It's not a one off.
Burst, and not just one big
protest or one election cycle.
No, it's constant effort,
constant attention, deep
commitment from a lot of people,
often for a very long time.
Like generations.
Think of building something
complex like a space station.
You don't just assemble it and
walk away.
You need constant power,
maintenance, upgrades to keep it
working.
Society's ideals are like that.
So what happens when that
initial burst, that passion,
inevitably starts to fade?
Because it always seems to,
doesn't it after the first big
push.
Right.
And when that energy fades, the
source says, society doesn't
necessarily collapse or reverse
dramatically, but it slips back.
The formal things might stay,
the laws passed, the policies
created, the institutions set
up.
They might still exist on paper.
But the oomph is gone.
Exactly.
The spirit is gone.
They become, in a way, just
relics, hollowed out structures.
They lose their real
effectiveness, their power to
transform.
And that is cultural entropy at
work, slowly, subtly, eating
away at the substance of change,
leaving the framework but
draining the life out of it.
It's the difference between
having a law and having that law
actually change how people live
and behave everyday.
Precisely.
The intention is there on paper,
but the impacts just dwindles
without that ongoing energy.
And we can see this pattern play
out historically, can't we?
The source points to some really
telling examples.
These case studies of the fading
flame.
Let's talk about the civil
rights movement.
Huge energy in the 50s and 60s,
massive victories.
But what happened after that?
Yeah, by the 70s eighties, that
incredible explosive momentum
had slowed down a lot.
The widespread public enthusiasm
for pushing through the really
hard structural changes needed
beyond ending legal segregation.
It faded.
The big obvious targets were
gone in a way.
Right.
Formal segregation was
dismantled, which was
monumental.
But as the source points out,
racism didn't just disappear, it
adapted.
It became more subtle, more
systemic, embedded in
institutions in ways that
require deeper, more persistent
effort to tackle.
And that effort wasn't
sustained.
The crucial point the source
makes is that the immense energy
needed to keep pushing to
dismantle those deeper systems
simply was not sustained at the
same level by the broader
society.
The landmark victories were
essential, but not enough on
their own to stop the entropic
drift.
When the initial energy died
down, the focus shifted maybe
from collective struggle to
individual achievement, and that
societal commitment just wasn't
consistently there.
And it's not just these huge
decades long movements.
Think about something like
Occupy Wall Street that felt so
powerful, so disrupted back in
2011.
Global attention.
Oh, absolutely.
Occupy had a massive, immediate
impact.
It drew crowds.
It really made headline with its
critique of economic inequality,
but ultimately it dissolved
relatively quickly.
Why?
What happened to the energy?
It failed to translate that
initial explosive energy into
lasting structures, clear
leadership, or concrete policy
changes.
It showed just how fast a
movement can lose its grip if
that first wave of energy isn't
channelled into something
sustainable.
New forms of energy,
organization, strategy,
institutional power weren't
generated quickly enough.
So the enthusiasm was there, the
outrage, but not the structure
to resist the natural decay.
That seems to be the case.
The spirit was strong, but the
resilience against entropy
wasn't built in.
And then more recently, Black
Lives Matter began with such
incredible force, global impact,
real solidarity after a horrific
events.
But the source notes that
widespread support has
definitely seen a dip, a wane as
attention moves elsewhere.
And the source says something
pretty stark here.
The energy of outrage cannot
last forever.
That really hits home, doesn't
it?
It raises a critical question
about movements driven mainly by
that immediate emotional
response.
It really does.
How do you sustain things when
the initial shock and anger
inevitably subside?
And if you connect all these
examples, the pattern seems
pretty clear.
Unfortunately, without finding
new ways to constantly renew and
channel energy, energy that goes
beyond just the initial outrage
entropy, it tends to win out.
It's less about defeating an
active enemy.
And more about constantly
fueling the system, pushing
against its natural tendency to
just settle back into
indifference, inertia, that
comfortable low energy state.
The fight isn't just against
opposition, it's against decay
itself.
Wow, that's a really sobering
way to think about it.
The idea that entropy just
quietly wins if you don't
actively fight it.
And this isn't just about
movements fading, it also helps
explain things like backlash and
apathy.
Right?
They're not just random
reactions, they're part of this
entropic process.
Exactly.
Cultural entropy isn't only
passive decay.
It actively manifests in things
like backlash when movements
make constant demands for
change, especially demands that
feel challenging or critical to
people's identities or ways of
life.
People feel attacked.
Well, the entropic middle, that
huge 7090% group, they feel
threatened.
It disrupts their comfort zone,
their desire to avoid conflict.
It creates friction, discomfort.
And their pushback, the source
argues, isn't necessarily deep
ideology, right?
It's something more basic.
That's the key insight.
It's often out of fatigue, not
ideology.
They're just tired of being told
they are wrong, tired of feeling
blamed or guilty, tired of being
told everything they love.
Maybe their traditions, their
history, is oppressive.
It's not necessarily hate, it's
exhaustion and feeling judged.
Right.
They feel overwhelmed, unfairly
targeted.
So what do they do?
They retreat into silence or
react with anger.
And here's a fascinating claim
from the source.
Moral campaigns often create
resistance not by fighting hate,
but by inadvertently waking up
resentment in people who are
just tired, uncomfortable, or
feel attacked.
It's a defensive reaction to the
perceived pressure.
They just want it to stop.
OK, so that's backlash.
A defensive reaction fueled by
fatigue and feeling pressured.
What about apathy?
That feels even quieter, maybe
more dangerous.
Apathy is presented as the other
face of entropy, and yeah, maybe
more dangerous because it's so
quiet, so invisible.
It's less dramatic than
backlash, but just as effective,
maybe more so, at eroding
progress.
And does it work?
Most people, again, do not hate.
They simply stop caring.
Not actively choosing
indifference maybe, but just
letting it happen.
They aren't fighting change, but
they're definitely not helping
it.
They're not contributing their
energy.
What does that look like in
practice?
Their behavior is this quiet
withdrawal.
They might not, at slogans,
agree in principle that
something is a good idea, but
then they just go back to their
lives.
They actively avoid the friction
of change, the effort, the
discomfort.
You don't want to rock the boat.
Exactly.
And the insidious thing about
apathy is that they do nothing
to help, but they also do
nothing to harm, at least not
directly.
But in this framework of
cultural entropy, that lack of
energy input, that quiet
withdrawal, is precisely how
progress erodes not with a bang,
but with a silent fade into
indifference.
Entropy wins when everything
just settles into an unengaged
state.
That's genuinely chilling
progress just dissolving into
apathy without anyone really
noticing.
And this leads us to a really
critical point the source makes
about a lot of modern activism,
particularly anti racist efforts
focusing heavily on symbols.
Yes, this is a key observation.
The source argues that many
current efforts often target
symbols.
Think about the big campaigns.
Remove statues, rename schools,
rewrite language to be more
inclusive.
These are very visible actions
They.
Definitely make a statement
they.
Do they're tangible markers of
changing values meant to address
past wrongs and signal present
intentions?
But, the force argues, while
these symbolic actions are
important, maybe even necessary,
they don't always create
lasting, deep change by
themselves.
And they might even.
Backfire.
That's the argument.
While they make statements and
can be validating, they do not
always create lasting change.
The underlying structures often
remain untouched.
And yes, the source suggests,
they may even feed backlash.
Why?
Because people in that entropic
middle who crave stability can
feel attacked, not persuaded.
They see it as an assault on
their heritage or identity, not
a move towards systemic
fairness.
Potentially.
And the energy driving these
symbolic fights, often the
energy of outrage, it rises and
falls quickly.
It's powerful for a moment, but
maybe not sustainable for the
long hard work.
A structural transformation.
So the stark reality, according
to the source, is that after the
symbols.
Systems remain.
Inequality remains.
Entropy remains.
The deeper issues, power
imbalances, access disparities,
ingrained biases, these aren't
always fixed by changing a name
or removing a statue.
And the quiet force of entropy
keeps working on those
unaddressed systems.
OK, so if focusing too much on
symbols isn't enough, what is
the deeper challenge?
What's the alternative strategy
proposed by the source?
It sounds like a major shift is
needed.
It absolutely is.
The crucial shift isn't just
removing symbols, it's building
systems that resist decay.
It's about embedding progress so
deeply into how society
functions that it doesn't depend
solely on temporary passion or
constant outrage.
Making it the default almost.
Kind of, yeah.
The source gives concrete
examples, like laws must be
enforced, not just passed.
Having a law is one thing.
Ensuring it's applied fairly
everywhere, all the time
requires ongoing vigilance,
robust enforcement, oversight.
That's the hard, often boring
work.
Less glamorous than a protest
for sure.
Definitely.
Or narratives must be told, not
just posted.
This means continuous
storytelling, education,
cultural reinforcement through
schools, media, art, community
dialogue.
Not just a viral tweet or a
campaign slogan.
It's about shaping the
underlying understanding over
the long term.
And values.
Values must be lived, not just
declared.
Turning ideals into everyday
practice, into the normal way
people and institutions operate.
That's the really tough part,
and the inherent difficulty.
All the systemic work requires
quiet patient energy.
Energy that's hard to keep up.
Exactly.
It's hard to sustain because it
doesn't offer quick wins,
dramatic moments, or emotional
highs like symbolic fights often
do.
It's slow, often invisible work.
Which raises that key question
again.
How do movements cultivate that
kind of steady, enduring energy
for the long haul?
How do you make system building
compelling?
That quiet, patient energy that
feels like the Mount Everest of
social change, doesn't it?
Something movements always
grapple with.
And we can see this entropy,
this decay in action when we
look at specific policies,
right?
Even things designed to promote
fairness just seem to fade away.
Yeah, the source provides some
stark examples of policies just
fading when neglected.
Think about affirmative action.
It was designed to actively
counteract historical
discrimination, but it's been
rolled back in many places.
How did that happen?
Was it a big public fight?
Not always, the source argues.
It wasn't usually through open
hate or some dramatic showdown.
It was often through slow legal
erosion and public disinterest.
A series of court cases, state
ballot initiatives, a gradual
chipping away combined with the
public just losing focus or
support, textbook entropy
winning through quiet neglect
and waning attention.
It wasn't blown up.
It just slowly crumbled.
Like that unmaintained building
we talked about.
And we see similar patterns
with, say, voting rights too.
That feeling of access slowly
shrinking.
Absolutely.
Voting rights protections have
weakened over decades, again,
often through gradual changes.
Maybe new ID laws here reduce
polling places there, voter roll
purchase, things that don't
always feel like a direct attack
but cumulatively make voting
harder for some.
It's that slow loss of focus on
robust access and enforcement.
And school integration, another
example.
Significant gains were made, but
then integration stalled as
schools re segregated, not
necessarily because of new
segregation laws, but often due
to housing patterns, local
choices, prioritizing
neighborhood schools over
diversity goals, and just losing
the energy and focus needed to
maintain integration efforts
like busing.
Without constant effort, the
system just reverted.
So the pattern is undeniable.
None of this was the result of 1
dramatic act.
It was entropy, the slow loss of
focus.
And this even effects something
as powerful as national unity
after a huge crisis.
You'd think those moments would
be resistant.
You would think so, but
apparently not.
Even incredibly powerful moments
of unity aren't immune.
The source uses 911 as an
example.
Remember how people talk about
solidarity?
About being united.
Yeah, it felt very real at the
time.
It did.
But look now, 2 decades later,
the source states flatly that
solidarity is gone, replaced by
deep divisions.
And, it argues, this same
pattern repeats after every
crisis, be it a disaster, a
tragedy, a pandemic.
Energy surges.
Collective focus sharpens
intensely for a moment.
Then it falls.
And the system defaults back to.
It returns to its lowest energy
state, indifference.
It's fascinating and kind of
depressing how quickly even
profound shared experiences can
be overwhelmed by this natural
drift back towards disengagement
and fragmentation.
It shows just how relentless
entropy is.
This has been incredibly eye
opening.
It really brings us to the heart
of the matter, identifying the
real fight and figuring out how
to move forward, knowing about
this quiet, powerful force of
cultural entropy.
Absolutely, and circling back,
the source puts it very bluntly.
Any movement aiming for real
lasting change, whether it's
creating a new anti racist
America or achieving any other
major societal shift, must face
the truth.
The real enemy is not just
extremists.
They exist, they're harmful, but
they're not the main barrier.
They exist.
They cause immense harm, no
question.
But the source argues they
aren't the primary long term
obstacle.
In fact, they're loud.
Visibility might even distract
us from the deeper, quieter
threat, this quiet drift of
cultural entropy.
And how does that specifically
hinder progress in a way that
overt opposition maybe doesn't?
Well, entropy makes progress
fragile.
It constantly undermines gains
from within, not by attacking,
but through neglect,
indifference, things just
falling back.
It swallows movements when their
energy runs out, leaving those
empty shells we talked about.
And, crucially, it shapes the
psyche of most Americans who
prefer comfort to conflict.
That deep human desire for ease,
for avoiding friction.
Exactly.
That preference makes the vast
majority susceptible to this
entropic pull towards inaction.
It's not a single battle you can
win, it's a constant current you
have to swim against.
OK, so if that's the real enemy,
this quiet drift, what do
movements do?
Shouting louder isn't the
answer.
Shaming doesn't seem to work on
the entropic middle.
So what's left?
Right, the source is clear.
Activists must do more than
shout.
The absolute imperative is to
build energy that lasts, energy
that isn't just reactive, not
just fueled by outrage or
crisis.
It needs to be generative,
sustainable, something that
pulls people in for the long
haul.
Crucially, the source says, they
must tell stories that invite
people in rather than pushing
them away.
This suggests a major shift,
maybe away from confrontation
and judgement towards
persuasion, empathy, finding
common ground, creating a shared
endeavor people want to be part
of instead of feeling attacked
or alienated by.
Building bridges, not just
walls.
Focusing on shared benefits
maybe?
Perhaps it's about cultivating a
broad base of steady, quiet
effort, not just relying on a
vocal fuse.
Temporary bursts.
So the future of any movement
really hinges on fighting
entropy by overcoming inertia,
building something that lasts.
What does that look like
practically beyond just telling
better stories?
How do you make progress?
Self-sustaining.
It means going going beyond just
moral pressure, which can
backfire.
It requires building systems
that work on their own, even
when passion fades.
This is the hard part, the
unglamorous part, but the
essential part.
Institutionalizing change.
Yes, embedding it into habits,
policies, structures that don't
need constant vigilance or
emotional fuel from a tired
public.
It means, as the source puts it,
turning ideals into habits so
strong that they survive when
the slogans stop.
Making fairness and justice the
default setting the normal way
things work, even when no one's
actively campaigning for it
anymore.
That's the goal, creating a
culture where progress isn't a
constant, exhausting fight, but
just the foundation of how
things operate.
That's a really powerful vision
for lasting change, and it
brings us to the final take
away, the ultimate conclusion
from the source, which feels so
important.
It says that the new anti racist
America, or any major ideal will
not win by defeating a few loud
opponents.
It wins only if it could
overcome the quiet force of
inertia that lives in the hearts
of most people.
And that, the source says, is
harder than defeating hate.
It really is harder, isn't it?
It's the slow, steady work of
keeping a culture alive when the
energy to do so runs low.
It's building resilience against
that natural tendency towards
disorder, nurturing ideals
through constant quiet effort,
sustaining progress.
When the world naturally wants
to drift towards indifference,
it completely reframes what real
change requires.
It shifts the focus from the
dramatic fights.
To the quiet, persistent, maybe
uncelebrated work of sustaining
a culture against its own
tendency to fall apart.
It's not about shouting louder.
It's about building deeper,
stronger foundations.
So we've really unpacked this
idea of cultural entropy today.
We've seen how this concept from
physics gives us a powerful,
maybe unsettling, explanation
for why progress is so hard to
maintain.
It's often not about the loud
fights, but about this quiet,
relentless drift, this tendency
for systems to decay without
constant fresh energy.
Hopefully you, our listeners,
now have a new way to look at
why initiatives lose steam, why
backlash sometimes happens
seemingly out of nowhere, and
why just turning up the volume
might not be the best path to
lasting systemic change.
This deep dive should give you a
more nuanced view of social
dynamics and the real, often
hidden challenges involved.
Yeah.
So what does this all mean for
you?
Maybe think about this.
What systems or habits in your
own life, or maybe in your
community need that constant
quiet energy just to keep them
from drifting into disorder?
Or indifference could be a
personal goal, a local project,
even just maintaining important
relationships.
And if the big societal battle
isn't primarily against a loud
minority, but against a vast
quiet majority driven by comfort
and inertia, how about we need
to change our approach?
Maybe focus less on temporary
outrage and more on persistent
invitation, building shared
purpose and doing that patient,
unglamorous work of creating
self-sustaining habits and
systems.
Something to think about.